[Musique]
donnez-nous des armes pour que nous
récupérions nos terres c'était le cri du
coeur de voloteki aux Occidentaux il a
finalement été entendu des chars lourds
allemands et américains notamment vont
être livrés à Kiev c'est un tournant
qu'on va essayer de comprendre avec nos
invités ce soir général Trincant bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous ancien chef de la
mission militaire française des Nations
Unies bonsoir Isabelle Lasserre bonsoir
Myriam
rédactrice en chef adjointe au service
étrangers du Figaro et ancienne
correspondante à Moscou bonsoir Denis
stral koff bonsoir bienvenue dans cette
émission vous êtes journaliste à RFI et
spécialiste de la Russie enfin bonsoir
Richard faut-il vous présenter Richard
Verny dans cette émission correspondant
France Europe du quotidien suisse Blic
et spécialiste des questions européennes
enfin bonsoir Jean-Louis Thieriot je
crois que vous êtes à distance avec nous
merci d'être là vous êtes député des
républicains de Seine-et-Marne et
vice-président de la commission de la
défense à l'Assemblée à tout à l'heure
j'imagine Emmanuel que la guerre en
Ukraine vous intéresse elle nous
intéresse tous je vous donne la parole
dans un tout petit instant mais on a
besoin de planter le décor avec mon
complice Stéphane blackowski
convaincueillir tout de suite pourquoi
l'Occident a changé d'avis à 200
secondes pour nous le dire le chrono de
Blacko pour démarrer
pour vous accueillir Stéphane du haut de
votre estrade bonsoir à tous Alors ces
chars de combat l'info du soir c'est
donc que les Allemands vont livrer des
chars de combat aux Ukrainiens donc on a
invité plein de gens très compétents
pour en parler donc vous me donnez 200
secondes pour lancer le débat donc on va
commencer par prendre notre temps on
fait une pause voilà on va commencer par
un petit flashback on ferme les yeux on
essaie de se souvenir ce qui se passait
il y a un an jour pour jour c'était le
26 janvier 2002 souvenez-vous à l'époque
Jean-Luc Mélenchon Marine Le Pen disait
jamais les Russes attaqueront les
ukrainiens et pourtant déjà à l'époque
il y a un an les Allemands avaient
livrés des armes à l'Ukraine parce que
quelqu'un se souvient de quel arme avait
été livré à l'époque bon allez trêve de
suspense je vous donne la solution
figurez-vous qu'à l'époque les Allemagne
avaient livré 5000 casques aux
Ukrainiens et le maire de Kiev avait
remercié c'est sympa les gars la
prochaine fois vous pourriez peut-être
nous livrer des oreillers vous voyez il
avait un peu mal pris cette livraison
mais vous avez compris que ce que je
voulais souligner c'est que depuis un an
il y a quand même une sérieuse escalade
dans ce conflit et c'est justement ça
qui fait peur aux Allemands c'est ce
risque d'escalade parce que c'est bien
de mots de livrer des chars aux
Ukrainiens pour qu'ils se défendent mais
si c'est pour se fâcher avec les Russes
qui veut se fâcher avec les Russes donc
donc avant de livrer ces fameux chars
léopard aux Ukrainiens les Allemands se
sont dit que ça serait bien d'être
d'accord avec les Américains parce que
les américains ils ont des défauts je
veux bien dire ils ont même beaucoup de
défauts en attendant c'est les plus
forts je vous montre le classement des
dépenses militaires dans le monde on
peut faire un petit cocorico on est dans
le top 10 enfin ce qu'on retient de
cette image c'est quoi c'est la
puissance militaire américaine qui
domine le million de dollars en millions
de dollars mais vous imaginez bien que
c'est avec ça qu'on achète des armes
donc maintenant pour livrer des armes
des chars aux
Ukrainiens les Allemands voulaient que
les Américains sortent de la même barque
et écouter ce qu'a dit que je Biden hier
soir
aujourd'hui j'annonce que les États-Unis
vont envoyer 31 chars Abraham sans
Ukraine soit l'équivalent d'un bataillon
ukrainien le secrétaire Austin a
recommandé cette mesure parce que cela
renforcera la capacité de l'Ukraine
défendre son territoire et à atteindre
ses objectifs stratégiques
et ben voilà puisque les Américains sont
d'accord pour envoyer 31 chars à
l'automne sans doute les Allemands eux
bah voilà veulent bien aussi avancer
avec 14 chars léopards de donc on va
enfin regarder ce char bah il a disparu
45 km/h on est là vous voyez donc le
canon le général trinquant nous
expliquera un peu moi ce que j'ai retenu
en tant que Babyliss c'est que c'est un
moteur de 1500 chevaux qui consomme 400
litres 100 donc il va y avoir des
dépenses de carburant à alimenter pour
faire fonctionner toute cette cavalerie
je vois bien que les 200 secondes ne
tirent à leur fin tout le monde
s'impatiente on expliquera vous aurez le
temps pourquoi les Français ne livre pas
de Charles Leclerc alors que les
Allemands eux livrent leurs charges
leurs chars léopard je voudrais juste
conclure sur la réaction du président
ukrainien quand il a appris que on lui
livrait en fin des chats on l'écoute
nous devons ouvrir la fourniture de
missiles à longue portée à l'Ukraine il
est important que nous développions
notre coopération en matière
d'artillerie
nous devons commencer à fournir des
avions à l'Ukraine
bon bah voilà là on connaît la prochaine
étape les missiles les avions je vous
laisse débattre je vous laisse juste
avec une image derrière
orienter le débat voir un petit peu ce
que je voulais dire à travers ce papier
elle arrive attention voilà je dis pas
plus mais à mon avis c'est une piste
pour votre débat engrenage merci
Stéphane je voudrais d'abord vous
entendre chacun sur la portée
géopolitique de la décision on va venir
au char ce qu'il permet exactement
comment former les Ukrainiens etc
Isabelle Lasserre des armes lourdes
est-ce que ça ça veut dire que les
Occidentaux ont changé de position par
rapport à leur soutien militaire
vis-à-vis de l'Ukraine oui
clairement ce sont les armes lourdes ça
va permettre de c'est vraiment des les
chars lourds auront un poids particulier
dans la dans la guerre en Ukraine donc
ça signe peut-être un tournant ou pas
d'ailleurs mais c'est vrai que ce sera
plus pareil qu'avant il y a eu un
glissement dans l'aide des Occident
plutôt à l'Ukraine depuis le 24 février
dernier et là c'est la première fois
d'abord qui a une telle unité en fait
malgré les désaccords de coulisses et de
façade il y a une vraie unité entre les
grands pays occidentaux avec une prise
de conscience que la guerre va être
longue
et pour une fois aussi tout le monde est
d'accord sur le fait que la négociation
n'est absolument pas possible donc il va
falloir aider les Ukrainiens dans le
long terme et le faire assez rapidement
c'est un changement la négociation avec
Poutine n'est pas possible c'est ce que
veut dire Isabelle lacer ça c'est un
changement parce que on a eu
l'impression quand même côté allemand
côté français ça a été même critiqué que
il y avait toujours cette idée de
préparer l'après de tenter les
négociations les coups de fil d'Emmanuel
Macron était très critiqués ça y est les
Occidentaux considèrent qu'on ne peut
rien attendre de Poutine ils ont compris
que le président Poutine ne voulait pas
négocier qui l'organise la réussite
comme un état en guerre même s'il
n'emploie pas ce mot-là il s'est adressé
il y a je crois 4 semaines à des
officiers en disant maintenant la Russie
s'organise l'économie s'organise et pour
faire la guerre donc c'est l'option
russe du long terme de gagner sur le
long terme et je pense que cette option
a en contrepartie l'espoir que les
occidentaux vont briser leur unité et je
pense que la décision de fournir des
chats ouvre l'inverse c'est-à-dire que
les Occidentaux restent unis soutiennent
l'Ukraine et je pense que c'est ça le
choc majeur pour le président Poutine il
sait que lui prépare la guerre sur le
long terme mais que les occidentaux font
la même chose et que donc il va y avoir
une vraie difficulté pour lui ça veut
dire que maintenant pour l'Occident la
seule option c'est la victoire de
l'Ukraine on peut dire ça comme ça moi
j'ai des doutes je les ai exprimés pas
plus tard hier sur ce plateau c'est à
dire que on parle beaucoup d'offensive
ukrainienne et les chars lourds seraient
là pour y contribuer je crois que le
chiffre qui avait été avancé pour
pouvoir constituer une offensive c'était
300 chars on en est encore loin si on
fait le compte il me semble plutôt qu'au
fond on est via les chars dans un
message très politique effectivement le
message adressé à Vladimir Poutine
c'est-à-dire nous serons prêts nous
aussi à tenir au côté des Ukrainiens
est-ce que par contre ces livraisons
vers la différence sur le terrain
rapidement point d'interrogation et
deuxième chose à propos de la rhétorique
et bien la rhétorique est toujours la
même nous ne sommes pas cobelligérant
disent les Alliés puisque nous
n'intervenons pas sur le terrain mais il
faut reconnaître que avec la présence de
charlour ce discours devient quand même
un peu plus compliqué à tenir Jean-Louis
cherio la présence de de chars de combat
léopard II allemand Abrahams américains
challenger Royaume-Uni ça veut dire que
les Occidentaux franchissent un pas sont
de fait plus impliquées dans cette
guerre ou entrer dans cette guerre
[Musique]
donc on connaît le tropisme américain
des Allemands on sait les divisions
qu'il y a dans leur gouvernement mais je
crois que là on a une très belle
occasion ratée de montrer l'Europe
puissance j'ai envie thérion revient
vers vous je vous donne la parole dans
un instant mais les réactions russes on
va tout de suite les voir dans le sujet
de marcophobie la première de ces
réactions c'est ce matin nouvelle frappe
russe contre Kiev qui a fait 11 morts
nouvelle salle de missiles donc alors
que sur la ligne de front la Russie
affirme progresser de nouveau à la fois
près de bermout à l'est et aussi dans la
région de zapporja dans le sud du pays
Marco Polo
véhicule pulvérisé bâtiment soufflé ces
dernières heures la Russie aurait tiré
une trentaine de missiles élancé des
dizaines de drones contre son voisin
dans son viseur des infrastructures
énergétiques à hauts desa mais aussi la
capitale du pays qui est où les attaques
ont fait 11 morts et 11 blessés des
bombardements qui interviennent au
lendemain de la décision des Occidentaux
de livrer des chars à l'armée
ukrainienne Moscou promet de les
détruire nous considérons cela comme un
engagement direct dans le conflit et
nous voyons que cet engagement grandit
en jeu plus de 100 charges occidentaux
des léopards des challengers des Abrams
il pourrait apporter une aide cruciale
aux Ukrainiens confrontés à de multiples
offensives russes sur une ligne de front
quasiment immobile depuis plusieurs mois
des offensives meurtrières dans cet
hôpital ukrainien les pertes sont
lourdes pour ce chirurgien des
livraisons de char modernes pourraient
tout changer j'ai un terrible exemple on
a pris en charge un jeune dankiste avec
tout le visage brûlé
son char a été touché par une frappe et
le réservoir d'huile à exploser l'huile
à aspergé toute sa tête je sais que s'il
avait été dans un char moderne au
blindage plus résistant il ne serait pas
dans cet état problème les blindés
occidentaux ne seront pas opérationnels
avant plusieurs semaines voire plusieurs
mois les soldats Ukrainiens devront
d'abord être formés sur ces machines
bien plus sophistiqué que leur temps
actuel des T12 de fabrication soviétique
le Pentagone va très bientôt commencer à
former les tankistes Ukrainiens qui
manient les chars afin qu'ils soient
prêtes à intervenir lorsque ces chars
seront sur le champ de bataille pour
leur difficile de savoir où et quand
l'état-major ukrainien pourrait engager
son corps de blindé ses chars d'assaut
vont-ils servir à contenir les assauts
russes de leur côté les États-Unis
tablent sur une contre-offensive
ukrainienne au printemps
Moscou a réagi par l'intermédiaire du
porte-parole provocation on a le
président de la Douma qui avait même
employé le mot de catastrophe mondial ça
s'était avant la décision on a même la
télérus propagande russe qui dit c'est
simple si ça arrive près notre frontière
on envoie les chats à Berlin c'est
apprendre à au sérieux tout ça ou pas je
pense qu'il est quand même un problème
que ce mot catastrophe provocation ils
ont été prononcé par des responsables
russes assez souvent depuis le début de
la guerre et ça c'est un grand
changement si vous voulez c'est
important les chars bien évidemment mais
ce qu'on observe aujourd'hui c'est même
plus important c'est qu'il y a autre
chose qui est brisé c'est la propagande
des Russes car avant on parlait toujours
de ces lignes rouges on imagine toujours
qu'il y a les rouge qui est le pont de
Kirch à côté de la Crimée qu'on peut
imaginer que les frappes sur le
territoire les territoires russes c'est
un cours de la ligne rouge maintenant on
parle plus de ce concept là on a bien
compris
j'ai fait par l'Occident quoi qu'il est
fait par le temps la Russie n'a pas des
moyens de réagir de manière efficace et
c'est pour ça que même si on boit tout
ça des discours assez infantiles à la
télévision russe
le risque d'escalade a trop paralysé les
Européens qui est important c'est que ce
discours de l'escalade celui que si
jamais vous il devrait plus d'armes il y
aura une escalade encore plus profonde
il était utilisé par les propagande de
Moscou et c'est ça donc quand on parle
de l'escalade on sert à quelque chose à
au moins qu'ils sont prononcés en faveur
du Kremlin donc certes il faut bien
réfléchir à ce concept-là mais dans tous
les cas la Russie va quoi qu'il soit des
armes qui vont arriver sur le sol
ukrainien et bon faire tout pour
connaître cette guerre il y aura pas un
désescalade si jamais on arrête les
légions des armes général trinquant je
crois que l'escalade qui consiste à
apporter depuis les premiers casques
fournis jusqu'au léopard il y a une
escalade depuis 11 mois mais tout ceci
s'entend dans un vaselot le champ de
bataille que représente l'Ukraine il y a
une ligne rouge la frontière russe il ne
faut pas franchir la réunioneuse il y a
une autre ligne rouge il ne faut pas
franchir la limite de l'OTAN ça c'est
pour les Russes entre les deux il y a un
champ clos c'est comme au Moyen-Âge on
combat à l'intérieur et puis on verra
quel est le résultat à l'intérieur alors
pas d'escalade à l'extérieur
expliquez-nous en quoi ça change tout
parce qu'on se dit c'est très compliqué
il y a une maintenance importante une
formation nécessaire c'est les
équipements électroniques technologiques
de pointe est-ce que ça va être efficace
sur le terrain alors comme vous parlez à
un tankiste je vais être clair c'est
l'arme de la décision c'est comme ça
qu'on l'appelle ceci étant ça ne change
pas tout tout seul une offensive telle
que les Ukrainiens veulent la monter ça
nécessite des chars mais si nécessite
aussi des véhicules blindés
d'accompagnement mardeur Bradley qui ont
été annoncés il y a déjà
un jour ça nécessite une protection
anti-aérienne armement antiériens que la
France se propose de fournir ça
nécessite de l'artillerie pour tirer sur
les dépôts de munitions et de carburant
de sa nécessite de moyens de génie pour
permettre aux chars de franchir
au pardon
de franchir les champs de mines donc
c'est l'ensemble de ces moyens
interables voire intéraarmé si on met
des avions et des hélicoptères qui
permettront de réussir une offensive et
pour finir c'est la capacité de
l'état-major ukrainien à monter cette
manœuvre pour prendre un exemple
historique qu'on connaît bien lancé une
attaque de char contre la ligne Maginot
ça marche pas par les Ardennes ça
fonctionne donc il faut arriver à monter
tout ce système là c'est pour ça que je
dis c'est l'arme de la décision c'est
important mais ça ne marchera pas tout
seul monter une opération et avoir
l'ensemble des moyens qui permet
effectivement d'enfoncer les lignes
russes
n'arriveraient pas tout de suite que ça
prendrait du temps on parle du printemps
on vue d'une offensive potentielle côté
russe côté ukrainien sur ses grandes
plaines quel est le calendrier comment
les occidentaux vont justement soutenir
au-delà des chars possibles en fait il y
a quand même un espèce de plantes
partage qui se qui s'est effectué depuis
plusieurs jours entre les alliés
occidentaux et par exemple c'est c'est
charlourds vont être accompagnés par les
chars légers AMX français qui feront
partie du livre auditif les Français
vont aussi sans doute livrer du matériel
supplémentaire en artillerie et en et en
défense aérienne donc tout ça va se
mettre en place rapidement sur le timing
c'est compliqué à dire ça dépend en
partie de la météo c'est-à-dire que tout
le monde parle du printemps mais il y a
cette fameuse Raspoutine ça au printemps
cette boue qui en fait est obstacles
très important pour les chars parce
qu'elle les en raye en fait on peut plus
avancer quand cette quand ce déjà quand
le dégel alors que c'est à peu près
cette période qu'il devrait arriver
après ça dépend de mars avril ça dépend
du moment donc ça peut être aussi en mai
juin c'est difficile à dire et puis ça
va aussi défendre des pentes de quand
est-ce que les Russes ont aussi prévu
leur offensive la mobilisation un petit
peu repris mais c'est de la mobilisation
générale qu'on annonce n'a pas encore
été
déclaré ni même mis en pratique de
manière systématique donc il va sans
doute rien se passer avant le mois de
enfin avant le printemps en fait
Emmanuel peracomo vous regardez ce
tournant parce qu'on comprend tout ce
que c'est un tournant c'est pas
simplement Charles et Charles voilà il y
a quelque chose de qui se passe
militairement dans le soutien des
Occidentaux il était temps où vous êtes
inquiet il était temps mais je me
souvenais quand Stéphane blackowski a
commencé pour dire qu'il énorme nous
étions encore en apparence de paix
j'étais invité je devais me rendre à
Kiev au l'arsenal bougfer qui est la
Foire du livre de Kiev où je suis
souvent allé avec Paul Auster avec
Philippe Sands qui est un avocat
écrivain anglais et puis on y allait
pour rencontrer André gourcoff le grand
écrivain
ukrainien et je me souviens que André
que j'ai eu au téléphone m'a dit écoute
je pense qu'on va devoir annuler parce
que les choses se tendent ici beaucoup
de gens croient que c'est la guerre et
je disais mais où est la guerre et puis
ça a été annulé André courcoiff est
resté sous les bombes à Kiev on lui a
prévu une voie de sortie etc il m'a dit
non je ne peux pas les quitter
maintenant et j'ai pensé à tous ces
écrivains qui étaient venus nous parler
auparavant venant du Dombas venant de
Crimée nous alertons alors que nous
étions on va dire insouciant entre
guillemets ou inquiet mais pas aussi
voilà donc tout ça me rend très ému et
profondément concerné voilà je suis en
permanence en contact avec des gens
là-bas avec des gens aussi à Moscou avec
des gens Moldavie avec finalement je ne
sais pas sorti des frontières mais ça
bouge dans tout autour et tout le monde
est inquiet voilà je suis pas un tant je
suis pas spécialiste de géopolitique je
suis juste un citoyen très ému
nous sommes un seul et même peuple sur
Terre
nous sommes voilà
alors
expliquez-nous le ministre
ukrainien de la défense aujourd'hui il
dit très clairement dans les colonnes de
l'excellent Figaro d'Isabelle
meilleur accueil possible bienvenue oui
oui on veut bien les accueillir c'est
c'est cher français pourquoi on ne les
livres pas est-ce qu'ils ne sont pas
assez efficaces ou nombreux
non je crois que le principal problème
quand on prend une décision militaire
c'est de savoir est-ce que c'est utile
ou pas aujourd'hui
le corps des Leclerc en France je crois
qu'on a 222 Leclerc c'est un chien lourd
compliqué comme pourra jamais remplacer
donc ça veut dire que ce que l'on peut
apporter à l'Ukraine ça serait
probablement c'est ce sur quoi on a
travaillé un escadron de Leclerc 14
Leclerc et c'est 14 Leclerc à soutenir à
entretenir avec tout le maintien
conditionnelle qui est extrêmement
compliqué donc je crois que la France a
intérêt à se focaliser sur le les
matériels où elles peuvent vraiment
apporter le plus de choses je pense
notamment au César mais pas que mais
aujourd'hui ça aurait pu avoir un sens
comme effet d'entraînement maintenant
que la décision est prise à mon avis ils
vont déjà avoir des challengers des
léopards des Abrams c'est pas la peine
de rajouter une quatrième une variété de
Charlots donc c'est pas un moyen pour la
France de se dérober sur ce coup-là
c'est juste qu'ils ne sont pas
suffisamment techniquement son trop
compliqué c'est ça qu'on comprend c'est
pas trop compliqué simplement je pense
que la proposition d'études de l'envoi
d'un escadron était une proposition à
valeur politique c'était monsieur les
Allemands vous n'êtes pas seul on est
avec vous maintenant que les Américains
ce sont déclarés sur le plan purement
technique il vaut mieux avoir une
homogénéité d'un parc de chat donc là il
y a des léopards il y a des M1 c'est
homogène à soutenir c'est plus simple
même nos amis britanniques les
challengers je suis désolé c'est très
gentil de les avoir fournies mais ça va
complexifier le problème et si on
rajoutait plus des Leclerc ça serait
encore plus compliqué donc je pense que
c'est il faut jouer
utile il y a eu une utilité politique de
dire les Leclerc on pourrait les envoyer
avec les Allemands c'est une unité
politique a disparu puisque les
américains s'y conjoint et maintenant
sur le plan purement opérationnel ça
n'est pas vraiment un sujet mais sur le
plan du soutien c'est un vrai sujet et
maintenant jusqu'où aider vous avez
entendu Richard ferly l'appel immédiat
après les remerciements évidents de
volotemski qui demande maintenant des
missiles de longues portées 5000 km qui
demandent des avions de de chasse de
combat c'est légitime de sa part il est
absolument dans son rôle il est le chef
d'état d'un pays agressé face à un
agresseur extrêmement puissant et donc
la seule manière de se défendre c'est
d'avoir des armes à la hauteur au moins
de celle de l'agresseur c'est à dire de
la Russie est-ce que on va livrer ce
type de matériel personnellement je ne
le sais pas mais n'oublions jamais que
dans toute guerre même une guerre dans
un périmètre donné comme le disait le
Général il y a un risque d'engrenage il
faut quand même l'admettre il y a un
risque d'engrenage il y a un moment ou
peut-être vous l'avez dit la Russie
pourrait tenter une offensive offensive
percerez les défenses ukrainiennes et où
il faudrait leur venir en aide de
manière encore plus massive donc je
crois que ce risque d'engrenage il faut
pas le minimiser d'autant que dans
l'autre sens le général trinquant
faisait référence aux frontières de la
Russie alors là il y a quand même un
hiatus considère-t-on les Français de la
Russie avant la guerre ou maintenant
puisqu'il y a eu les fameux référendum
et vous le savez que les territoires
conquis sont désormais considérés par
Moscou comme des territoires russes des
mistralf sur les frontières pour Moscou
c'est le don de basse auto proclamé
russe après les forêts faire un dôme
en quelque sorte pour Moscou il lui faut
occuper encore plus je vous rappelle que
la Russie de manière officielle attachée
son territoire la région de parisienne
et la région dont la Russie occupe deux
ou trois pour cent à ce moment-là donc
on voyait donc quand on parle des
frontières bien on va vous montrer la
carte en même temps
sur le donc d'attaquer le plus puis donc
il a quand même la question qui était
spéciale de la Crimée car évidemment de
manière politique Poutine peut permettre
de perdre quelques tiroir avoir plus de
ce qu'il a déjà perdu on a vu que on a
tous dit que Christian ça sera une faute
absolue pour Poutine bah que même le
régime la survé que par contre les
Crimée c'est une chose spéciale pour les
Russes il faut bien le comprendre que
depuis 2014 on dit russe que c'est
intéressant qui est historiquement
attaché à la Russie comme pas le perdre
que c'est ça il est rouge si on revient
à ce polémique là respectivement et la
Crimée sera défendue par avec beaucoup
beaucoup d'audace par la Russie si le
travail c'est de la reprendre et surtout
que c'est là où Poutine va essayer de
juillet de jouer encore plus sur les
sentiments patriotiques et c'est là on
peut prévoir peut-être une mobilisation
ou des choses pareilles Isabelle
Lasserre vous qui avez des sources à la
fois politique militaire importante
qu'est-ce qu'on pense aujourd'hui dans
le camp occidental vous nous disiez tout
à l'heure c'est parti pour un nom de
guerre de plus on pense jusque là on a
pensé de manière assez différente
l'Occident est déjà un concept compliqué
et depuis le début de la guerre il était
divisé en partie c'est à dire d'une
partie l'Europe centrale et orientale
qui a toujours eu une position une
analyse
réaliste et juste de la menace russe
contre le camp qu'aujourd'hui qu'on a
appelé le donc c'était le corps et qui
considère aujourd'hui cette cette Europe
orientale
qu'on appelle le camp de la victoire que
seul une victoire
claire nette et précise des Ukrainiens y
compris jusqu'en Crimée puisque la
Crimée est ukrainienne que c'est la
seule manière de se débarrasser une fois
pour toutes de la menace du régime
poutinian et en face il y avait une
Europe qu'on appelait l'Europe de la
paix qui était essentiellement
représentée par Paris et par
Berlin et qui considérait que il était
possible d'ouvrir des négociations qu'il
était possible de convaincre Poutine de
s'arrêter et qui a pendant très très
longtemps essayé de donner une ouverture
à Moscou ça n'a pas marché aujourd'hui
il y a plus qu'un seul camp pour dire
comme ça de manière aujourd'hui non il y
a des il y a encore bien entendu mais
aujourd'hui il y a quand même une espèce
une unité à peu près reconstituée entre
les Etats-Unis et l'Europe avec des
certitudes petits les négociations sont
pas possibles petit 2 la guerre va durer
longtemps et petit 3 je pense que ce que
les Occidentaux ont compris ce qui était
pas clair jusque-là à Berlin et à Paris
c'est que en fait il ne s'agit pas
seulement d'une guerre entre la Russie
et l'Ukraine mais cette guerre a des
implications régionales et mondiale et
en fait les occidentaux y compris les
Français et les Allemands ont compris
parfois tardivement qu'en fait une
défaite de l'Ukraine aurait des
conséquences plus dramatiques que la
prise du risque de l'escalade en ce sens
que elle aurait des conséquences très
graves pour la sécurité du continent
européen pour l'avenir des démocraties
et puis aussi pour l'avenir du droit
international que finalement l'Ukraine
effectivement défendait les valeurs
européennes les valeurs de la démocratie
et donc notre camp et qu'il fallait
s'opposer aux autographes aux
autocraties
de l'humanité et des démocraties mais
malheureusement pour les ukrainiens et
pour la situation sur le champ de
bataille c'est de date sont en 2024
c'est l'élection présidentielle en
Ukraine et c'est l'élection
présidentielle aux États-Unis donc si
vous regardez le calendrier politique
vous vous dites que 2023 probablement
c'est l'année où on se fait face et 2024
peut-être à rajouter l'élection en
Russie absolument tout à fait donc on
voit bien que l'année politique sera
2024 de l'un en déduire que 2023 sera
l'année militaire général trinquant au
fond c'est une forme de nouvelle guerre
froide alors certains guerres chaudes
mais cette espèce de revirement de
changement d'époque on peut le dire
comme ça dans le camp occidental vous
partagez l'analyse d'Isabelle il y a un
changement d'époque complet moi je
reviens toujours au début de la guerre
et c'est pas pour des douanes et Poutine
ne voulait pas faire la guerre il
voulait faire un coup d'état qui est il
voulait renverser le gouvernement de
Kiev sous la pression militaire mais le
renverser il voulait pas faire la guerre
et puis c'est planté complètement pour
prendre un terme bien connu et là il
s'est plus sortir de son tunnel du coup
il demande à l'armée de faire la guerre
elle était pas prête pour ça de façon
globale mais encore moins ponctuellement
et il n'arrive plus à sortir de ce
tunnel et aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'il
fait il dit maintenant la Russie est un
alors il emploie pas le mot guerre il
employait une fois je crois mais la
Russie est en guerre et nous organisons
tout autour de la guerre ce qui au
passage pour un autocrate et plus simple
parce que on organise la société autour
de lui-même donc c'est c'est très
compliqué et nous
occidentaux comment pouvons-nous
accepter qu'un autocrate décide de
briser les traités de priser les règles
internationales en utilisant la guerre
et c'est sa faute à lui et lui ne sait
pas comment s'en tirer on verra si cette
unité occidentale continue de durer j'ai
envie Thériault pour terminer ce débat
j'aimerais vous soumettre quelques
chiffres on sait que cette décision
Berlin notamment a été prise sous la
pression des pays de l'est de la Pologne
et aussi de des trois états balles quand
on regarde les contributions à
pourcentage de budget de la Défense des
pays européens c'est très clairement les
pays de l'Est qui donnent le maximum de
leur budget défense 41% pour la Lettonie
37% pour l'Estonie et on voit 0,5% du
budget de la défense seulement va à
l'Ukraine alors évidemment quand on
ramène ces chiffres au milliard
évidemment c'est les Américains qui sont
largement en tête on va voir ce ce
panneau l'aide militaire par pays en
milliard c'est les Américains et puis
évidemment la France est mieux classée
et et on comprend pourquoi puisque on a
on a forcément une différence plus
importante qu'est-ce que ça vous dire au
fond que notre aide reste quand même
assez assez faible en France est-ce
qu'il faut répondre à elenski en le
soutenant davantage d'un point de vue
militaire oui vous savez je crois
d'abord qu'il faut quand même regarder
les chiffres en valeur absolue ça n'est
pas ridicule loin de là d'autre part on
est aussi en fonction de l'état de ses
finances publiques et vous connaissez
l'état des finances publiques français
c'est pas particulièrement glorieux
j'ajouterai un troisième point mais je
ne citerai pas de pays dans ce que
j'évoque d'après les informations que
j'ai tout ce que nous envoyons ou à peu
près tout fonctionne et fonctionne bien
parfois c'est un peu plus compliqué que
cela donc je crois qu'on n'a pas rougir
de ce que l'on fait la France fait ce
qu'elle peut elle peut sans doute faire
mieux et puis on a aussi un autre
élément qui ne soit pas oublier c'est
qu'on a un outil industriel qui même
s'il est mis à contribution peine à
produire davantage et on si on veut
envoyer plus de buts 45 aujourd'hui on a
déjà une tension maximum donc l'aide
probablement fera l'objet d'une montée
en puissance progressive merci beaucoup
va s'arrêter là sur quoi je me tourne
vers vous deux à quoi il faudra être
très attentif dans les semaines à venir
sur le conflit qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce
qui va bouger qu'est-ce qu'il faut
regarder il faut regarder le type
d'armes après les chars lourds qui vont
être ou non
envoyer à l'Ukraine si l'appel de
Zelenski étant est entendu qu'est-ce que
vous regardez vous attentivement
j'aimerais être un camp progression des
promesses derrière j'envoie des chars
quand est-ce qu'ils arrivent quand
est-ce qu'ils peuvent être engagés parce
que si c'est pour engager dans un an
c'est pour ça que la promesse américaine
me surprend beaucoup je rappelle qu'il y
a des chars américains à Ramstein donc
il y a pas besoin de les sortir des
usines il suffit de les sortir des
stocks américains donc voilà ça me
laisse un peu pantois on va regarder ça
merci beaucoup merci être venu sur le
plateau de LCP pour ce débat vous restez
avec moi emmanuel Pierrat dans une
dizaine de minutes les partis pris de
nos affranchis ce soir splendeur et
misère des partis politiques ce sera la
carte blanche de Pierre-Henri tavoyau
Jérémy Beaudot la natalité un impensé
d'Emmanuel Macron et puis retraite rien
n'est joué avec les LR ce sera le
bourbon de Stéphanie Despierres mais
d'abord quand les avocats font
l'histoire on va se plonger dans votre
livre Emmanuel Pierrat chronique
sensible je le disais est très personnel
sur ce métier dont on retrouve les
premières traces chez les Grecs et oui
on voit tous là dans l'invitation de
Marco pommier et on en parle avec vous
juste après
si on vous invite Emmanuel Pierra c'est
pour votre dernière ouvrage
quand les avocats font l'histoire
une chronique sensible sur plusieurs
siècles qui resituent la place des
grands avocats du barreau français tous
ont un iPhone motif l'avocat c'est
surtout prendre la parole pour quelqu'un
d'autre défendre par uniquement la veuve
et l'orphelin la veuve leur volant
parfois l'assassin mais défendre vous
êtes avocat écrivain certes connus pour
votre expertise dans le droit littéraire
de nombreux livres au compteurs l'un des
plus marquants sans doute celui sur la
censure mais votre dernière ouvrage
replace les grands noms devenus des
acteurs cachés de notre histoire
l'avocat naît dans l'Égypte antique
qu'il est en Grèce sur l'appel le logo
graphe il est caché il souffle les plus
horribles au justiciable on trouve
certainement absurde qu'au moment où on
dit il faut sortir de là et parler des
grandes affaires ce livre débute dans
une Grèce antique où l'avocat resté muet
au fil des siècles son rôle s'élargit
jusqu'à protéger les droits des citoyens
quel que soit leur position sociale
l'affaire Calas le collier de la reine
sans oublier le procès historique
d'Alfred Dreyfus
[Musique]
avec le temps les avocats ont du composé
avec la médiatisation comme le laisser
déjà entendre à l'époque Gisèle Halimi
nous tenons la publicité des débats
parce que nous pensons que la femme
victime ne doit pas se sentir coupable
et qu'elle n'a rien à cacher vous êtes
attachés au plaidoirie qui parfois
transformer faits divers en affaires
d'État dans votre ligne de mire les
loquence ou encore les subtilités du
droit
inaccessibles vous parlez d'une société
judiciarisée et ajoutez
l'été nord des grands procès sont les
héritiers d'une longue histoire alors
question Emmanuel Pirard quelle
importance devons-nous leur accorder
alors l'importance des avocats dans la
société elle est capitale puisque ils
remontent à l'Antiquité et que cette
vocation a accompagné l'histoire de
France ces soubresauts politiques chaque
grande étape chaque grand tournant de
notre République ou même de l'ancien
régime alors c'est logo graphe moi ça
m'a passionné parce que j'ai regardé
l'Antiquité grecque au départ l'avocat
il est caché et il est muet il est caché
il est comme un souffleur il est dans
une trappe il est en dessous du tribunal
et il parle juste ici pour lui donner et
les arguments et les phrases et les
juges Athéniens se mettent à trouver que
les Justiciers sont très mauvais c'est
leur propre cause qu'il plaît donc ils
sont inquiets pas très éloquents et en
plus ils connaissent rien aux arguments
juridiques au bout d'un moment on dit
finalement montrez-nous ceux qui
souffrent montrez-nous les logos graphes
parce que vraiment ils seront sans doute
meilleur que ces acteurs de pacotiques
sont les justiciables et prévenus les
accusés et on voit apparaître on voit
naître l'avocat ils prennent place et
après sous la romantique ça sera les
grands players et laboratoire va
commencer
le droit dans son histoire est toujours
lié aux religieux on le voit au
Moyen-Âge notamment parlons de la bille
la robe elle date elle date de la
soutane en fait bien sûr la robe
d'avocat que je ne porte pas ce soir
parce que je ne suis pas au Palais de
Justice et vous ne me jugerez pas mais
en Kawa mais c'est une robe qui est une
soutane de curés évidemment elle est
faite avec 33 boutons te rappelle on va
dire un âge christique elle est
évidemment celle d'un curé c'est quand
on rentre encore au Palais de Justice
île de la cité qui est devenu la cour
d'appel on voit très bien l'osmose entre
la Sainte-Chapelle et les salles
d'audience et puis les uns regarder les
vitraux des salles d'audience en pensant
qu'ils sont chapelle et vice et versa la
République et laïque la justice l'est
aussi mais elle est empreinte évidemment
d'une grande histoire religieuse et la
robe dans laquelle on se glisse permet
aussi d'endosser le rôle et peut-être en
la quittant de prendre la distance
critique aussi de des grandes éloquences
et de chair et d'église et de barreaux
et de la chambre donc ce sont leurs
casiers où on se passe des messages on
portait cette toc ce petit chapeau rond
noir qu'au début du 20e siècle et puis
on l'a posé pour ne pas la rapporter
chez soi parce qu'on risquait de
l'abîmer donc on l'a posé dans un petit
casier et j'ai toujours un numéro de TOC
c'est à dire un endroit où on glisse en
théorie sous un chapeau qui n'existe
plus on glisse le courrier qui vient du
tribunal donc on peut me joindre à l166
qui est mon numéro de casier pour
déposer ma toc que je n'ai plus mais je
reçois encore du courrier judiciaire
antiquité moyen-âge on va très vite la
révolution là c'est passionnant
Robespierre Danton on peut citer il y en
a mis des moulins et beaucoup d'autres
c'est eux qui invente la Révolution les
avocats oui ce sont des plaideurs
Robespierre est avocat Arras il descend
au monte à Paris comme on voudra fort de
ces procès et fort de son arboratoire
c'est d'abord ce qu'il en porte on sait
véritablement
sa capacité éloquente à convaincre sa
capacité à tenir des discours pendant
des heures et des heures comme on le
plaidait à l'époque et donc c'est une
c'est une révolution d'avocat Danton
comme est d'ailleurs l'erreur de se
défendre lui-même puisqu'il pense qu'il
est si bonne avocat qu'il arrivera à
sauver sa tête et évidemment le procès
est un peu on va dire
tronçon du coup de Ré comédophile pour
défendre celle qu'on appelait plus la
reine déjà la citoyenne Capey qui était
accusé de tous les mots lorsque shove
est comédie d'office il est à peu près
18 ou 19h et il doit plaider le
lendemain c'est le procès de
Marie-Antoinette il y a 50 chefs
d'accusation qui vont de la primoration
avec l'ennemi l'inceste sur son fils des
choses incroyables il a peu de temps
pour l'avoir la prison du Temple et puis
on lui dit voilà vous devez terminer
vous devez la quitter et préparer votre
plaidoirie et on a les notes de
plaidoirie de chevalard qui sont restés
et on va au fur et à mesure que la
chandelle s'amenuise il écrit plus que
des interjections quelques mots et ça
sera le grand témoin parce qu'il écrira
tout ce qui s'est dit et notamment quand
la reine dit quand on l'accuse d'inceste
et qu'elle répond en disant je décale
arguments qu'on en appelle à toutes les
maires de France et il note c'est donc
le historien en quelque sorte l'acteur
de ce procès historique alors on va vite
et on enjambe l'histoire la Troisième
République c'est la République des
avocats Gambetta Bloom get Poincaré il
débarque ici à la Chambre des députés
vous parlez beaucoup d’alleurs des liens
entre avocat et politique qu'est-ce
qu'ils apportent à la représentation
nationale qu'est-ce qui change dans les
débats parlementaires avec l'arrivée des
avocats ils apportent c'était le causes
de la tribune particulière c'était le
cas c'est osmose ou c'est l'aller-retour
permanent entre le palais de justice et
puis l'Assemblée nationale ou le Sénat
ils apportent véritablement cette espèce
de passerelle il se replie quand il
perdent les élections il redevient la
vodka et puis le reparte du barreau de
Toulouse ou d'Albi pour d'un seul coup
revenir si j'ai à la chambre et donc
c'est farcisant de Vincent Auriol à
Poincaré ce sont des hommes d'État
extraordinaire moi j'ai grandi par
admiration pour ces noms que portaient
les les rues de ma banlieue de naissance
il y avait en permanence et écrit
Gambetta homme politique et écrivain
et on voit un avocat en réalité qui
continue sur le combat qui a été celui
de toute sa vie alors l'avocat plein
devant les juges mais il plaide aussi
devant l'opinion devant les médias et
aujourd'hui devant les réseaux sociaux
votre ami parce que vous allez ce
chapitre pour lui rendre hommage Jacques
Verget est l'inventeur du procès
médiatique on va parler de ça mais
d'abord expliquez-nous pourquoi vous
l'appelez le lumineux qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire
quand même et de Paul potes avocat de
Klaus Barbie il invente cette histoire
de tribunal médiatique mais qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire cette expression là
c'est surtout quand vous alliez chez
Jacques Vergès dans son bureau dans son
cabinet il y avait trois portraits de
lui posant à côté l'un de Mao l'autre de
Pol Pot de barlon Brando ça montrait les
pires heures de l'histoire du 20e siècle
avec la Shoah sans doute et puis de
l'autre côté la fascination pour le
cinéma il avait descendu j'ai défendu
pardon devant le tribunal de Papeete où
elle était accusée Polynésie d'avoir
assassiné ou tuer son compagnon et donc
Jacques Verget c'est un avocatier qui a
inventé aussi le procès de rupture
c'est-à-dire l'idée selon laquelle on se
rejette contre le système judiciaire qui
vous jugeait cette pendant la guerre
d'Algérie quand il défendait le FLN
évidemment et comme je disais la limite
donc qui a été de l'autre camp mais
formidable avocate qui comme le disait
dans votre sujet tout à l'heure disait
il faut plaider devant le public il ne
faut pas que ça soit huis clos et puis
il faut continuer devant la télévision
et continuer à porter sa cause parce que
c'est comme ça qu'on fait avancer aussi
le droit et la société
souvent les les clients les plus
sulfureux que vous avez défendu Gabriel
Matzneff par exemple ou Denis Baupin
vous allez dire attaquer certains médias
en diffamation après avoir gagné enfin
suite est-ce que est-ce que au fond les
les dossiers défendus par des avocats on
pourrait parler de Vergès aussi
existe quelque chose des avocats
eux-mêmes vous n'avez pas que ces
clients là vous en avez beaucoup
d'autres il y a des stars aussi il y a
des grands écrivains mais est-ce qu'il y
a un fil conducteur dans le choix des
dossiers et des clients qu'on représente
oui bien sûr forcément
le goût de défendre des formes ça n'est
pas endosser une cause ces pensées qu'on
sera meilleure stratège ou meilleur
argumentaire si je peux me permettre
pour le dossier de quelqu'un et ce qui
est dommage c'est que la société très
moderne celle des réseaux sociaux juge
l'avocat comme s'il était son client
aujourd'hui donc je me vois d'un seul
coup alpaguer par des tweets où l'on
confond ce débat essentiel ou se rôle
essentiel dans une démocratie sans
avocat sans cette fonction de défendre
et de représenter en justice quelqu'un
alors il y a plus d’état de droit il y a
plus de débats contradictoire et on se
retrouve de l'autre côté de la barrière
dans un monde qui est celui avec lequel
nous sommes en guerre l'affaire bopin
c'était avant Mitou mad9 et le livre de
Vanessa springora après
est-ce que vous diriez parfois tout de
même que on a le sentiment que la
société sur ces sujets là sur les
questions de violences sexuelles et
sexistes avancent plus vite que la
justice elle avance très vite elle a
fait changer la justice faut pas se
tromper alors il y a ce débat important
sur les violences faites aux femmes et
sur le sexisme il faut se rendre compte
que malgré tout les tribunaux et puis
les commissions de police sont
énormément progressé grâce à ce débat en
deux ou trois ans trois quatre ans
l'écoute n'est plus la même vous rentrez
dans un commissaire de police quand vous
accompagnez quelqu'un qui a porté
plainte ou qui est gardé à vue vous avez
des oursins
il faut pas comprendre le problème c'est
un débat avec deux points de vue sans
preuve sans témoin la plupart du temps
donc c'est très difficile nous restons
sous un régime de présomption
d'innocence et en revanche l'accueil
l'écoute qui est partait aux victimes
aux parties civiles elle est très
importante aujourd'hui elle est sur
notre perfectible mais il faut pas se
tromper on a fait des progrès absolument
abyssaux en quelques années et puis
parfois heureusement il arrive
heureusement que la justice se trompe et
on voyait des images les images de
l'affaire Dreyfus évidemment c'est
l'immense
erreur judiciaire par l'excellence il y
a pas eu de révision en revanche dans le
l'affaire de d'Oma Raddad
elle se trompe mais elle le reconnaît
très très rarement c'est le seul de la
dernière endroit où finalement des
hommes et des femmes ne sont jamais
responsables des décisions qu'ils
prennent moi je suis toujours fasciné
par les responsabilités des juges aller
scène d'un certain côté parce que
remettre en cause le pouvoir des juges
veut dire lutter contre l'État de droit
et en même temps on peut commettre les
pires pardon et ne jamais avoir fait
quelque sorte en payer le prix il y
avait encore il y a quelques jours ce
téléfilm sur l'affaire Outreau ou cette
série c'est la même chose vous voyez le
juge Burgaud pétrie dans ses convictions
qui sera juste entendu ici par
l'Assemblée nationale et ça sera tout
pour être muté dans un autre poste
simplement après avoir dévasté des vies
complètes et avec un mort qui se suicide
en prison donc il y a quelque chose il y
a quelque chose
réinventer bien sûr évidemment beaucoup
de juge même sont conscients de cette
difficulté dernière question de la jus
de la judiciarisation de la vie de la
société politique économique familiale
vous la redoutez ou pas alors les d'à
côté gratifiantes pour les avocats
évidemment et de l'autre côté elle est
déplorable le fait que on nous appelle
alors qu'on pourrait parler à son voisin
qu'on vient de nous saisir immédiatement
en disant je veux attaquer là où le
civisme et le bon sens permettrait de
résoudre bien des situations menaves
évidemment comme citoyen comme avocat me
réconforte ou m'enrichit comme citoyen
je suis consterné parfois et je
préférerais évidemment qu'on soit dans
une société où l'on plaide moins et
l'emplette de façon plus juste
quand les avocats font l'histoire de
l'Antiquité à nos jours vous l'avez
compris faut picorer il y a énormément
de de choses à apprendre c'est érudit et
puis c'est c'est un livre personnel
aussi où vous raconter votre parcours
d'avocat Emmanuel pierre on va terminer
comme chaque soir avec nos affranchis
leur parti pris vous allez le voir
Emmanuel Pierra ils vont vous faire
réagir on les accueille tout de suite
allez Pierre-Henri tavoyau du collège de
philosophie Jean Rémi Baudot de France
Info bonsoir les amis Pierre-Henri vous
allez ausculter l'état de santé des
partis politiques dans votre carte
blanche dans un instant après le
spectacle affligeant du PS et puis vous
j'aurais mis vous nous parlez d'un angle
mort un impensé le la natalité la baisse
de la natalité personne n'en parle au
sommet de l'État mais on commence comme
chaque soir avec le bourbon Express
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée c'est
vous qui nous l'a racontez Stéphanie
Despierre bonsoir bonsoir une histoire
de vote LR qui pourrait manquer sur la
réforme des retraites et oui c'est
l'histoire des républicains qui jouent
un rôle clé dans cette réforme mais qui
ne savent plus trop sur quel pied danser
alors si vous n'avez pas tout suivi je
vous refais le film le gouvernement n'a
pas de majorité absolue à l'Assemblée il
n'a que 249 députés lui manque donc 40
voix s'il veut faire passer sa réforme
il a donc besoin de la droite si les
républicains votent comme ils sont 62
c'est simple le projet du gouvernement
passe sans problème et donc le
gouvernement a besoin de la droite et
donc négocie avec la droite et oui
pendant les c'est une valse de
rendez-vous et de messages entre Eric
Ciotti le tout nouveau patron a des
républicains Olivier Marleix celui du
groupe et puis de l'autre côté Matignon
et le ministère du Travail la droite est
d'accord pour reporter l'âge légal mais
elle trouve la copie du gouvernement
beaucoup trop brutal et puis tadam le 7
janvier à la Une du journal de dimanche
regardez à gauche Gabriel Attal le
ministre des comptes publics à droite
érectionti de président donc des
républicains et au milieu ce titre
presque d'accord Éric Ciotti déclare
qu'il est prêt à voter une réforme juste
et quatre jours plus tard et bien il est
de retour à Matignon pour voir Elizabeth
borne là cette fois il veut négocier des
revalorisations pour les petites
retraites et à la sortie il crie
victoire
c'est un gain social de justice que nous
avons obtenu auquel nous étions attachés
il y a une injustice pour beaucoup de
retraités qui ont travaillé très dur je
pense notamment aux indépendants en
commerçants aux artisans aux
agriculteurs et ils verront leur
situation améliorées donc c'est une
étape importante et ce succès oui il est
dû à l'unité de nos groupes
parlementaires et il est dû aux
républicain bref il y a 15 jours tout
semblait régler les républicains les
voter la réforme des manuel Macron et
alors ça c'était il y a 15 jours depuis
rien ne s'est passé comme prévu et côté
LR Éric Ciotti a manifestement parler un
peu vite et oui certains députés les
républicains immédiatement ont été
furieux de se retrouver pièces et points
liés avant même le début des débats
l'assemblée et puis ils savent que cette
réforme est impopulaire de plus en plus
impopulaire alors la défense sur le
terrain et bien c'est compliqué et puis
le risque de le payer aux prochaines
élections alors le week-end dernier nous
sommes allés aussi sur le terrain dans
les vos avec le député Stéphane Viry
alors lui il est chef de fil des
républicains sur la loi retraite il
hésite encore c'est plutôt oui mais à
condition que et on l'a vu lors de cette
rencontre avec les adhérents les
républicains ils résument parfaitement
le piège qui attend la droite
si on est pour
le RN va nous taper dessus à bras
raccourci on est la majorité on est
macroniste il y a donc plus que le RL
qui représente l'opposition et une
alternance
si on est contre
le mérite d'être très clair alors pour
calmer les frondeurs et montrer que les
républicains n'ont pas tous cédé au
gouvernement Olivier Marleix à lui cette
semaine dégué de nouvelles exigences le
groupe vient juste de déposer un
amendement pour que les salariés qui ont
commencé à travailler avant 21 ans
puisse partir après 43 ans de cotisation
et non 44 comme le réclame le
gouvernement alors une fine est combien
de républicains voteront la réforme
impossible à dire pour le moment le
gouvernement a besoin d'au moins deux
tiers du groupe merci beaucoup j'ai tout
compris et pour ceux qui n'avaient pas
suivi c'était extrêmement clair on va
regarder ça de très très près ici à
l'Assemblée nationale les votes lèvres
sur sur les retraites retraite toujours
Jean-Rémy il y a selon vous un paramètre
qui n'a pas été discuté celui de la
natalité oui qui en 2023 prend la parole
pour parler de la natalité et replacer
la démographie dans le débat des
retraites en réalité pas grand monde le
sujet est totalement absent alors qu'il
mérite d'être posé car notre système de
retraite repose en grande partie
ressources du déclin de notre
civilisation ça n'est pas pour rien si
peut-être le grand modèle nataliste en
Europe c'est la Hongrie de Orban
évidemment Zemmour applaudit la réalité
c'est que c'est difficile aujourd'hui de
faire la promotion de la natalité
François Bayrou aussi et c'est un petit
peu alors soit on passe pour un vieux
réac soit pour quelqu'un qui n'a rien
compris au réchauffement climatique soit
pour quelqu'un qui veut exploiter le
corps des femmes bref le sujet est
devenu totchi et en réalité c'est un peu
une folie alors vous nous dites faites
des bébés ce soir j'appelle en tout cas
reposer les termes du débat à ne pas
laisser le débat uniquement à ceux qui
préfèrent les femmes au foyer ou à ceux
qui pensent qu'il est non citoyen et
égoïste de faire des enfants il y a des
leviers pour inciter les Français les
Français à refaire des enfants ça peut
passer par la fiscalité des allocations
dès le premier enfant ça c'est une des
propositions de Bayrou ça passe aussi
par une organisation sociale qui en fait
permet du temps en famille des carrières
mieux respectées quand les femmes
s'arrêtent le temps d'une maternité du
côté du gouvernement j'ai passé quelques
coups de fil il y a rien rien dans les
cartons la question de la natalité n'est
pas une priorité et pour vous dire comme
loin de la balle l'actuel projet de
réforme des retraites pourrait faire
perdre aux femmes l'avantage que leur
trimestre de maternité leur donner
jusqu'à présent il faut dire les choses
si on ne fait plus d'enfants notre
modèle social risque de s'effondrer et
sauf à recourir à une immigration
massive et dans ce cas-là ça pose
d'autres problèmes évidemment à long
terme cette baisse de natalité sera un
gigantesque problème économique social
et politique faites des fêtes des bébés
Emmanuel Pirat et il est très très
politique ce sujet aujourd'hui est capté
par plutôt la droite de la droite en
même temps il y a toujours un régime
législatif qui interdit de faire la
promotion des contraceptifs à part la
capote relié à l'épidémie de sida donc
moi je suis toujours fasciné c'est des
lois natalistes qui datent d'après la
Première Guerre mondiale et qui sont
toujours on va dire au détriment de la
possibilité pour les jeunes filles
d'avoir accès facilement à la
contraception par la publicité vous
savez qu'il est autorisé seulement en
France d'avoir la publicité pour les
contraceptifs féminins uniquement dans
la boîte où on explique dans le mode
d'emploi à l'intérieur de la boîte que
vous achetez en pharmacie donc il y a
deux débats il y a sans doute encouragé
la natalité et puis faire flotter
peut-être quelques
enfants
handicapé par le fait d'être enceinte on
enchaîne parce que le temps nous est
compté Pierre-Henri les difficultés du
Parti socialiste vous ont donné envie de
revenir sur les difficiles positions des
partis politiques c'est difficile d'être
un parti politique c'est la crise oui
alors vous connaissez tous la phrase de
François Mitterrand qui disait gagner
l'élection c'est très simple il faut un
candidat en pleine forme bon il faut
deux trois idées programmatiques et il
faut un parti en ordre de marche les
parties sont pas en ordre de marche
au-delà de la crise circonstancielle et
un problème de fond avec les parties
c'est que quand vous êtes en démocratie
démocratie ça repose sur la souveraineté
du peuple speup ça veut dire que le
peuple est 1 partie ça veut dire diviser
donc il y a un problème substantiel du
parti et il y a une petite voix
régulière qui dit les parties c'est le
népotisme le clientélisme les magouilles
électorales voilà c'est c'est parti sont
en effet STR
quand même de la vie démocratique oui
alors c'est le fruit de la convergence
de deux modèles il y a un premier modèle
qui est un modèle qu'on appellerait
libéral j'appelle ça le parti club c'est
à dire qu'il y a des citoyens qui
s'engagent un peu plus dans la vie de la
cité que les autres et puis qui vont
faire le qui vont faire le job qui vont
être actifs et ils vont faire vivre le
plus réalisme avec l'idée très profonde
que en fait si on veut éviter la guerre
civile il faut que les conflits soient
institutionnalisés et donc analyser le
deuxième modèle c'est le modèle que
j'appellerais le parti total ou
totalitaire c'est le parti communiste
c'est à dire l'idée folle dans le parti
qui vaut le tout qui est le tout
l'expression partie unique qu'on y
réfléchi totalement délirante mais qui a
une force extrêmement puissante c'est
que ce parti représente une société bis
on y met on s'y forme on s'y marie on
part en vacances on boit des coups en
militent ça accompagne la vie du berceau
à la tombe et ses forces formidablement
rassurant et pour vous ce sont les deux
modèles le club et le parti totalitaire
qui sont en crise oui pour des raisons
qui sont assez proches le club on
l'accuse de pas être assez démocrate
c'est un peu élitiste et puis le parti
total on l'accuse d'être trop religieux
au fond parce que tropédiologique et ça
ça marque les deux crises de ces parties
on a d'une certaine façon une crise de
croyance et une crise d'engagement du
côté de l'engagement on a aujourd'hui
des parties sans militants et des
militants sans parti son concurrencés
ces adhérents par des mouvements sociaux
un peu spontanés et quand on veut
démocratiser ces parties clubs et bien
il y a des primaires et ça aboutit à des
leaders sans leadership ça aboutit à des
majorités très faibles et ça aboutit
souvent à des frictions extrêmement
violentes le Parti socialiste d'un mot
comme vous voyez l'avenir de cette
l'avenir c'est très compliqué l'avenir
c'est de toute façon
le parti est aujourd'hui
subventionné très largement par l'État
et du coup couper de la société il est
vidé pas de sa substance parce qu'il est
financé par cet état qui est le fait
vivre
les idées c'est ailleurs dans des Sting
tanks et donc je pense que de toute
façon mais le chantier est immense c'est
pas effectivement
la réinvestissement idéologique que ces
parties vont peut-être renaître merci
passionnante chronique sur les partis
politiques vous avez fait partie d'un
parti je crois
j'ai été Europe Écologie Les Verts j'ai
été élu à Paris 6e et j'ai grandi dans
une ville communiste ou le parti faisait
tout et venez vous chercher à la sortie
de l'école avec Big gadget vous emmener
la bibliothèque municipale et les a
Triolet mais je m'en suis très bien
porté voilà
merci en tout cas merci Emmanuel Pierra
quand les avocats font l'histoire
c'est-à-dire chez Albin Michel merci
pour vos chroniques pour vos regards les
affranchis Stéphanie on se retrouve très
vite fin de cette émission merci à vous
de l'avoir suivi tout de suite votre
soirée documentaire avec Jean-Pierre
Gratien à demain
[Musique]